you are so much fun i've been in
situations where i hang around with you
and we're supposed to be working
uh and crafting something or making
something happen and we just goof around
and i'm imagining now you're working
with larry david on curb your enthusiasm
and i know larry must
delight in having you around just
because you're so much fun
yes so i did an episode of curb for next
season and
and uh and larry he loves he loves
old-time
impressions so he's like my full-on
audience like my small demographic
when i did vincent price on snl lauren
michaels came up to me he went i love
this but
why now
larry is just and if you can make larry
laugh he's like
but he loved um yeah like george
mccready and all these people
and but he loved bert lancaster and i i
used
and this is probably an impression that
a lot of young people don't know but
burt lancaster one of the great
film stars one of the great film stars
and people have been doing
impersonations in forever but i worked i
was a pa on this movie and the wardrobe
guy goes you know i
used to work for bert lancaster and i
brought him
chowder one day i'm gonna give that a
second
burt lancaster getting his chowder
getting his chowder
and they brought him his chowder and it
was in a paper bag
and he said bert lancaster looked in the
paper bag and he stared in there for a
long time
and then he looked up and he went oyster
crackers
you forgot the oyster cracker
and i did that and larry went
cause i just walked around going oyster
crackers
what you know you're a movie buff what
what films are you watching these days
uh i like to watch uh british crime
movies where you can't understand what
anybody's saying those are my favorite
kind
i was watching sexy beasts the other day
i love that movie yeah sexy beast is
great and
but you watch those and it's all like
all right we're going to go down
spain we're going to go down to spain
and i'm like all right they're going to
go down to spain
so then we've got a gal to do a job and
i'm like hey all right they're going to
get gala do a job he's like and that one
got a boyfriend
what and then they're in a restaurant
i'm like oh they're going to rob the
restaurant they're like oh
well the calamari i'm like oh they're
eating at the restaurant
oh okay oh they're on a plane okay
they're gonna hijack the plane now this
is what the story is about and it's like
i like this plane
and you're like oh they're enjoying
their flight oh this is
crazy you know you know so but i just
sit and watch those for
hours right and then audio commentary is
terrible because it's like this is the
scene where we lock
forward